welcome to this video FM Eddie marsala
who the heck is that even vr krishna qua
professional pianist oh my god ok so
this is not really good but it's not
it's not easy to play if you don't know
it exactly yeah c5f 3g5 it's good for
black but it's it's extremely messy if
you know the stuff here with white a
blitz game in a blitz game it can be
tough tough for black so we wouldn't see
how to do this the reason why this isn't
so great is because the dark squares are
suffering Wow here he wants he wants a
clean trade here that is crazy a little
bit might be fun probably wins upon a2
I completely overlooked that he can
simply support the pawn such a weird
structure of course overlooking sounds
we have read it because it's so easy but
I actually did not appreciate this did
he just as is 3m okay so that that
wasn't exactly the refutation of this
line and it can be refuted it's really
not good at all okay not like review
take refuge in terms of winning the game
but getting getting a substantial
advantage and I don't have any advantage
in absolutely not
yeah there's all kinds of mayhem your
own age 7 but why check yeah yeah yeah I
know but I was thinking it isn't all
that clear now here how to do this
I play this move what I want is this
reply now with the bishop is hanging and
Bishop e3 is cut the stretch and it
looks like a problem for wine main
thread is root G ADA winning the full
Roku check there was the strange game
push up g to mate white resin is that
that went downhill real quickly yeah but
I did not really refute this opening I
don't I don't quite remember how it
works I'm not quite sure I mean this is
ride any plates III yeah so stop which
gives Queen B 6 foot the reason why this
is usually considered questionable is
the week dark square so white has given
up his Bishop and he has completely bad
structure in terms of weaknesses on the
dark squares d5 now given by the engine
no I never studied this in detail I was
surprised at that the Queen trade was
was kind of that he was okay with this
because one one thing wrong with Flex
position is sometimes the Kings
situation but with Queens traded that
isn't a big deal with I completely I
know it sounds weird but I simply did
not appreciate II can't play III I
didn't see that somehow and I thought he
has to play if I awesome the
make any sense of course my train of
thought the end here I'm definitely in
some and some trouble okay at least I'm
playing the engine was some somewhat f5
it really makes sense that you to give
me to activate the pieces this this and
here yeah and now we cancelled
surprisingly i also thought like key
route g1 the group g1 kingi to this kind
of things white must be clearly better
here pieces I extremely active and my
king position is shaky and yeah I can
take which already and gives me a decent
position and shattuck shouldn't work
actually because now he's in some issues
and this is attacked as we have seen
rook f2 was losing and this should be
fri yes to give up the exchange but the
disin this already is this is done right
yeah that's the winner the bishop is
hanging for real the full bishop and
this is also on that's it story of the
game yeah this line is something that is
really considered questionable that I
don't really know how it is played ok
guys thanks for watching